[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
ken's show the ken coleman show deals
with careers you getting the job you
love his brand new book that came out
last week as went on sale last week
we've been pre-selling it but it hit the
actual shelves and shipped into your
mailbox
and so forth last week from paycheck to
purpose the
clear path to doing work you love on the
heels of that book actually uh launching
on the street date last week
we are launching pre-sale yesterday on
uh the first book i've done in eight
years
it's called baby steps millionaires how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can too it's on
pre-sale now you can get it at
ramseysolutions.com you can get ken's
book ramsey solutions.com
the pre-sale on mine like all of our
others has a whole bunch of goodies in
it including audio books and e-books and
100 worth of stuff to go with it so
check out books they are available a lot
of things you can't get this year for
christmas these books you'll be able to
get well baby steps comes out in january
but um
but you can go ahead and do the pre-sale
and put the uh i don't know wrap up
something under the tree yeah you put a
picture of it or something in a stocking
maybe take a picture by the way speaking
of pictures put it in ken's book i like
seeing the oh yeah thank you very much
thank you dave i appreciate that the
gift that keeps on giving uh so i like
the new picture by the way i mean not
only is it the first book in eight years
but we've got a uh updated pick looking
pretty cool there standing in the meadow
i mean i like the whole scene there it
looks like the sun rising did you take
that at six in the morning yeah we did
we went out to my farm
and did a photo shoot as as the sun was
coming up yeah it's fun and uh they did
a really good job with it um
and you know photoshop's amazing i've
said that yeah
i've said that i i one of my main
objectives with putting my face on the
book was if people if i ever get the
privilege to meet people they're gonna
go wow
whoa they really really glamor shot at
you
know our team does a great job so it's
it's good it's exciting stuff fun times
yeah fun times so check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com meantime here the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five
two two five manissa is with us in
austin texas hi menissa how are you
hi dave i'm doing good how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
so i was calling because
you don't know this but you your book
helped me to get out of credit card debt
good for you
thank you i started with my by myself
trying to to take care of myself and
then i showed my my parents but they
were skeptics and my mom finally got on
board and then my dad got on board so we
we no longer have credit card debt
um however now we're in the dilemma
where the house that we purchased
was a wreck so we had to sell it to an
investor and we're in limbo we don't
have
anywhere to
go the the housing market is so bad we
keep getting outbid for houses
and we tried buying a trailer house and
there's issue with land so
i'm i'm thinking i needed to go there
regularly too to find out how do i
invest so that i can
build my wealth i i know i i you're one
of one of the sections in your book says
to
get an emergency fund
and then do 401 of course i had already
had my 401
and
but i for some reason i can't get the
thousand dollars i can't even get a
hundred dollars and i don't know what
that is so i was hoping maybe you can
leave me in the right direction okay uh
who's we
your parents and you are doing all this
together
yes i try to do it on my own like after
i read the book i mean i mean you're
like you're like the house you own you
own with your parents
yes we did but we we had to sell it
because it was so it's sold so you don't
currently own a house with your parents
no sir we were trying to buy good don't
don't don't own a house with your
parents how old are you
i'm 52. don't own a house with your
parents
well they need me
well they they can get a place to rent
you can help take care of them but you
don't need to own a house with your
parents that's a this is a bad plan
yeah i completely agree with you okay
good then don't do it they agree with
you yeah so how much of the money did
you get money from the sale of the other
property
because we had to sell to a home
investor we didn't really get that much
but we have fifteen thousand dollars you
have how much um
fifteen thousand dollars okay and so you
have 7 500 for them and 7 500 for you
right
uh well they can have all of it i i mean
you're going to give them all of it okay
then what do you make a year
um
about 41 000. okay and how did you get
out of debt
we just
did your baby steps read well that's
baby step one's a thousand dollars you
said you couldn't do that
well then like we we that so i've been
trying to to do that but every time
something comes up that we need to start
taking money out okay there's not a week
you're 52.
there's a them and a you
yes there's no we
yes sir okay so you make 41 000 a year
and how did you pay off credit card debt
well um
so
you got on a budget and you found money
in the budget and you put it on the
credit cards right
well uh what i did was that we took all
of the bills and the one that was the
lowest we just split the
the balance three ways and we we paid
that and then we paid we did that for
each one of the bills until we got them
all paid off
okay
all right so you found a money in your
personal income to apply to the debt
correct yes yes sir so that's how you do
your thousand dollars
only now it's gonna be you and you need
to go find an inexpensive place to rent
give them the fifteen thousand set up
your life
and begin to work the baby steps with a
written budget you're not doing a budget
and you need to start doing a budget
immediately
so get on every dollar and download the
the world's best budgeting app and get
your get your budget going to where you
are doing this but monisa you have to
separate
you can love mom and dad
but you're 52 years old time to move out
of your mother's basement
time to quit sharing bills with your mom
and dad it is way past time
unless you have some kind of a a mental
disorder that doesn't enable you to live
on your own
but you need to do that and you need to
do it now and i don't think you do based
on talking to you yeah i i would just
add one thing when he said i want you to
ask yourself
you said they need me
but i wonder how much you need them and
you're not even aware of how much
they're a safety net for you for you not
to truly fly and to do what you're
supposed to be doing i think you've got
to really confront that i think at 52
it's time as dave said for you to strike
out and do your own thing and at 41 000
a year you can get that a thousand
dollar emergency fund pretty quickly
yeah and move through this and before
you know it
be truly in a great place financially
get the least expensive thing don't buy
a trailer
they go down in value get the least
expensive thing you can get to rent get
yourself started get and take all the
extra jobs you can take and get on a
written budget and begin to build the
thousand dollars and then work your way
on up through all of the baby steps and
you'll be just fine you can do this
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over 70 a month by switching to
pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
this is the ramsey show ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author with his new book
from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love is
answering your career and job questions
i'm answering your money questions we're
answering your life questions together
you jump in the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
ahmed as ahmed is with us ahmed in green
bay wisconsin hi how are you
hi dave uh i'm doing good how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so currently
i'm trying to transition from just
working as a gig worker i'm trying to
get into the cyber security field and i
was wondering if i should
get a degree or just work on it on my
own and get certification that way
certification
uh there is no evidence anywhere and i
would welcome your research to prove me
wrong there's no research that would
bear out that a degree is going to help
you get into cyber security faster and
make more money in fact there's such a
demand in this industry and it is white
hot it is probably the most uh not just
fastest growing but the most opportunity
long term with cyber security and
i i endorse a program called bethel tech
and they can train you in nine months
for if you cash flow less than thirteen
thousand dollars that's just one example
do your homework look at other people as
well but you don't need a degree to get
into cyber security if you get certified
and while you're getting certified you
are making connections in the field
talking to folks that are working in
cyber security getting ideas from them
at companies that are hiring directions
to go within cyber security
those two things getting certified and
getting connected is all you need to do
to get in
a four-year information systems degree
is an excellent degree field the
technical items you learn while doing
that are obsolete by the time you finish
the degree yeah
they're of no value
i've got we got a thousand team members
here i've got an in-depth security teams
internet
cyber security team obviously we've got
a lot of web presence and a lot of risk
and so we spend a lot of time and money
on cyber security and a four-year degree
in information systems is not a
requirement to join a team our size we
do look for the certifications in this
and we do want to see uh that you've got
some kind of hands-on experience
actually fighting to keep the hackers
out which is the full-time freaking job
these days but um yeah ken's exactly
right this is not a four-year degree
world the technology field in general is
not a four-year degree world
if you want to get it that's fine but
what you're after there is if what
you're after is the ability to get hired
it's not necessary
as a matter of fact it's not even
preferable because what you're learning
is processes and concepts not the
technical hands-on application because
the stuff you learn today
a year and a half from now be obsolete
you've got to have your hands on this
stuff to know what's going on in that
world
you blink and it all changes again
uh you know how your computer is uh
obsolete ken
you got it out of the box isn't that the
truth that's how about how it works this
freaking thing's a door stop six months
later that's right the number of times i
replace technology around here is
unbelievable the money we spend just to
stay
not on cutting edge but just to stay up
to speed cyber security included but
even hardware issues as well bobby's
with us in columbia south carolina hey
bobby welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave uh and it's george right ah
this is ken today but i'll answer it
with me george was with me yesterday
and dave i just want to say thank you
both um george is nicer than ken yeah
yeah
i can't i can't argue that he's the
nicest person on the planet he is yeah
he's nicer than all of us that's good
stuff good personality qualities right
there right yeah okay sorry about all
that how can we help
i'm basically you know recommended to
you from a previous boss and a longtime
friend of mine uh you know very humble
man uh man of god brandon blake thank
you very much i hope you hear this um
i'm kind of in a pickle right now dave
i'm 24 years old i'm a young father i
got a three-year-old i'll be three in
december absolute pride and joy in my
life and my biggest form of motivation
um and my wife and me we're still
together
um i'm currently living with some
relatives
and i've been here for about seven
months uh my wife was working full-time
and just switched to staying at home to
watching her son while i work full time
i just got a really nice job the best
one i've had since i've been working in
the professional field 401k offered paid
time off bonus structure things of that
nature
i'm in a very weird position though with
how to take you know i'm very young with
my professional career i want to set up
my foundation with investing properly
as we stand right now my debt i only
have about twenty thousand dollars of
debt seventeen thousand dollars in
student loans about two thousand dollars
in medical bills and how much do you
make
um thirty five thousand dollars a year
um if my bonus comes out the way that it
should this next year will be at forty
working 40 hours
40 hours a week yes sir
your baby's how old
uh he'll be three in december december
6.
what was your wife doing before she quit
she was working as a cake decorator for
lowe's foods um and has since lost her
position uh mainly due to it was during
covid so it got pretty hectic
um and right now she's just staying at
home and interestingly enough she also
has an international business degree
four-year university from rollins
but she doesn't have any direct
experience working in the field um not
even a job like a starting job that
would even be relatable to that yeah
what's the pickle that you're in you've
given us a lot of details what's the
pickle
my pickle is i have two options right
now um you know eventually inevitably i
want to move out um my mom and dad are
generous enough to allow me a little
allow me to live rent free um so i think
i'm having is living expenses and a
couple other payments
um but i need to figure out you know if
i mean obviously saving money is what
needs to happen um but where to put that
money is the question no there's not a
question you're you're broke and you're
living with your parents you need to
pile up some money in a savings account
and get out of there
yeah you don't need to start don't worry
about investing and don't start your
401k you're broken in debt
and you guys have got to do something in
this household to increase your incomes
so since you're only working 40 hours
you need an extra job and your wife
needs to start doing some freaking cake
decorating while she's at home with a
three-year-old
yeah no you're right you're not wrong
dave um and i guess my next question is
you know to make my the smartest
decision possible um you know my credit
score is pretty good at 700. um my
thought process was
getting either a mortgage on a house no
you're broke
you need to go get a one bedroom or a
two-bedroom apartment as cheap as you
can get and you need to pile up cash as
much as you can and you need to be
working 80 hours a week and she needs to
start working 30 hours a week when the
kids down
so she can get some other income coming
in you guys need to get your income up
50 to 70 000 immediately and start
paying these debts off and get out from
under your parents roof yesterday
yes sir my question is in regards to the
rent with renting i mean as you know
rental properties the money you put in
goes into a hole you don't get it back
honey you're broke
you're a renter
you don't buy a house when you're broke
you are broke and in debt you make
thirty five thousand dollars a year and
have a three-year-old you're 24 years
old you don't go buy a house right now
this house will be a curse to you you're
trying to mix long-term
issues in with your short-term
emotions and you need to get the
short-term stuff taken care of you need
a big pile of money for an emergency and
to move and to get out and you guys need
to get your incomes up and then you
begin to attack the debt and when the
debt is gone you build an emergency fund
a fully funded big emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses then
we'll start talking about saving for a
house you're not buying a house for
three two to three years from today if
you're wise
it's just hard dave because you know
with rent it's not hard
an additional it's not hard you're 24
you'll be 27 when you own your first
house it's not hard at all yeah somebody
has told you that renting is throwing
money away and you can't get past that
thought and it's simply not throwing
money away for two years when stacy and
i moved here to join dave this was the
move for me we took two years and rented
because we wanted to make sure we were
going to the right place we wanted to
make sure that we were going to lock in
and and dive in and we had to save money
to be able to get the kind of house that
we felt that we wanted to get we weren't
throwing money away that's a false
narrative and you're not hearing
the wisdom and the truth here that dave
just gave you the baby steps work every
time but only if you get this mindset
out of your head that renting is wasting
money renting is buying patience while
you're too broke to buy oh that's good
you're buying you're buying time
and honey you're you're so broke you
live with your parents
that's how broke you are you don't need
to go from that to owning a home
you you need to get out get the debts
paid off build up an emergency fund
build a foundation for your young family
slow your butt down
you're okay you got plenty of time
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work first go
to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage richie and carol
are with us hey guys how are you doing
good how about you better than i deserve
welcome where do you guys live knoxville
tennessee
knoxville all right good people i was
born just south of there in maryville
marvel
you have to say that correctly yes all
right so how much debt have you guys
paid off we paid off seventy nine
thousand five hundred and fifteen
dollars and fifty cents all right how
long did this take it took us 23 months
good for you and your range of income in
that two years um we started off at 58
000 and then we're on track this year to
be at about 108 000. wow
there we go what do you guys do for a
living
i'm an elementary school music teacher
and i'm in sales okay so worth the extra
50 grand in income i mean you doubled
your freaking income we did um so i
started off in a smaller job with not so
much pay and then um right after the
coveted pandemic when school started
opening up i
was hired into my teaching position oh
so you got like a full big job pretty
much yeah you're not you're working like
part time kind of uh yeah pretty much
yes and sales is good obviously it's
god's ups and downs yeah okay all right
so eighty thousand dollars in debt what
was it what kind of debt
it was a little bit of everything we um
it was credit cards car truck uh
motorcycles
loans crews we paid off a cruise
so you guys were like normal we were so
normal we bought everything on debt yes
we did unfortunately look at you awesome
okay so what happened two years ago how
y'all been married uh six and a half
years okay so uh after four years of
marriage or three years of marriage
someone says this ramsay stuff we gotta
try tell me how this happened what
happened so um it happened a little bit
before um i had found out about you um
through some friends and so i started
listening to your podcast um looking
through all your tools and everything
and i told him i said hey let's try this
he's like no i'm not interested no i
don't want to do this
and then about two years ago um he had
an emergency appendectomy oh
and so i was sitting in the emergency
room waiting and i was like there's no
way because with my income if something
worse were to happen
we couldn't be able to pay our bills we
and i was i was in freakout mode um and
so
when we got home from the appendectomy i
looked at him and i said we have to do
now that you lived if you don't do this
i'm gonna kill you yeah yeah pretty much
and so um that was kind of our i had it
moment um and so since then we
really really buckled down um it took
him a little bit to get on board but i
mean first couple times i'd you know she
was just like let's try this dave ramsey
thing and
um i was just like no i just i was
stubborn just like everybody else is
well i'm a salesman i always tried to
outsell my stupidity and right
i just tried to out earn it right yeah
and so after uh after the the surgery i
was just like okay let's give it a shot
and
we started off we had a little bit of
money put back and we paid off one of
our credit cards
and as soon as i paid off that credit
card i've got a massive adrenaline rush
and i was just like okay what else can
we pay off
and it just kind of went from there he
was fine
yes yes yes
that's when he finally was on board um
and then we finally were able to
start really getting some debt paid off
so i was catching the youtube uh feed
through my peripheral vision while i was
looking at y'all i saw the motorcycle
pop up did you keep it or did you sell
it no i actually sold it to pay off uh
the hospital the appendectomy oh she
told me she said it's not a good trade
no no
that's an appendix for a motorcycle
well we um that was part of our debt we
paid off the motorcycle and then we
turned around and sold it to pay off the
medical debt what did it sell for it
looks like a great bike it uh i sold it
for 2500. oh wow and that that covered
everything and i told her when i sold it
naturally i said so we pay this off and
after we're debt-free yeah i want to buy
another bike and she said okay
absolutely
yeah a better one
fund for that so pay cash for it yeah
that's that's what you live like no one
else later you can live like no one else
exactly ride like no one else later you
can ride like no one else yes that's
good way to go man
cool very cool thank you so you guys
just when you once that adrenaline hit
you leaned in and 23 months later boom
boom we did there was some struggles of
course what was the biggest struggle
uh
probably um having to say no a lot and
being like no we can't go out no we
can't do this or do that no we don't
need that even though your friends look
at you like you lost your mind they did
they were like
what just go out and have fun everyone's
going to be in debt everyone's going to
have debt just go out and have fun and
we're like no we don't want to do that
we don't want to be in debt anymore it's
wearing us down it's worn us down our
entire marriage and we just don't want
to do it anymore so i i love when when
couples share the struggle
i want to know in your situation
what did you two do for each other or
individually to keep pressing on through
the struggle
what kept you moving we um we had to be
each other's rock yes there were times
where he wanted to quit where i was like
no
we're doing so well we have to do this
we have to keep going there were times i
wanted to quit and he said no no we
can't you know we just we really had to
push each other to keep going um i mean
and and we would pull up the podcast we
would listen um dave we watched your
story a lot on youtube about where you
came from and where you're at now we
said brought me in tears every single
time to hear the story so it was just
one of those things where we had to
remind ourselves what we're doing it for
um so later on when we have kids of our
own that they don't have to live like we
did
i love that i want to ask you take me to
one of those moments well either one of
you i don't care but what did you say i
know that you were each other's rock but
what was that thing maybe that you said
besides watching dave's story and seeing
that desire future certainly that's
motivating but what'd you say to each
other hey
stick with us what'd you say we would be
out somewhere it didn't matter what
story went to if we wanted to buy
something that we knew we could take
that 20 40 50 whatever towards debt
and
naturally my immediate response is
because i want her to you know she wants
to buy something i want her to have sure
naturally and at the end of the day i
would be like you know if you want it by
and then we'd sit there and stare at
each other and be like what would dave
say
we would we would be like we would we
would get down and kind of a well
i'm tired i don't want to do this
anymore and we would be like what would
dave say like what would dave do at this
point
and i think that kind of kept us going a
lot and also i mean it's like this past
weekend i had a funeral i had to go to
my uncle passed away in hernando florida
so we drove there and back
and the 10-hour drive back i can promise
you we had 10 hours of dave ramsey in
the car oh my gosh we did i don't even
want to be in the car
and it also took a lot of prayer too a
lot of prayer
good luck
trust you know god telling us
so you did it all off the podcast or the
total money makeover book or financial
piece university we did financial peace
university oh yeah we did it um in our
home we didn't do the class um i think
during the pandemic well yeah online
yeah
and so we didn't during the pandemic
most mostly when we watched it sure um
but that really helped us to kind of
figure out our direction and where we
need to go so proud of y'all thank you
y'all are amazing what a great couple
thank you you just really you got the
right spirit on you you're going to be
able to do anything you want to do
you're on your way to being baby steps
millionaires before you know it now that
you hit this stride so very very well
done we got a copy of the legacy journey
for you to celebrate that next chapter
and a copy total money makeover for you
to give away to somebody help get them
started because you've been talking
about this you can't shut up about it i
actually gave um i gave the total money
makeover book to a co-worker of mine she
was struggling
and when i gave it to her
she did like what anybody else would do
even i've done it put the book aside
yeah i asked her i said have you read
the book
and she said
no i haven't read it yet i said okay
now i'd come back next day hey have you
picked up the book yet she says no
and so finally i met her at work one day
and she said hey i wanted to tell you
something i said what's that she said
that book that you and carol gave me i
said yes she said me and my husband were
having a um
a struggle a fuss over money we don't
have any money right now and i said okay
and she said
i prayed to god and asked him
to help me and she said god told me i
gave you a book
[Laughter]
all right guys count it down eighty
thousand dollars paid off in 23 months
make it 58 to 108.
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one we're
i debt-free it
i already gave you a book
wow
that'll preach
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well last week was launch day on ken
coleman's new book from paycheck to
purpose they were shipped to your
mailbox if you'd ordered one if you
haven't gotten one yet you can get it
now we'll ship it to you immediately the
clear path to doing work you love and
then yesterday we released pre-sale on
the first book i have done in eight
years it is called baby steps
millionaires how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
it's all about step-by-step how to
exactly become a millionaire and i prove
to you
without without beyond a shadow of a
doubt
that you c that you
you know i'm talking to you
that you
can do this
that's pretty cool
it's not out of reach it's doable
so if you want to pre-order this book
actually comes out january the 11th but
it went on sale on pre-sale yesterday
when you pre-purchase a ramsey book we
typically bribe you to buy it early by
giving you a whole bunch of goodies and
this is no exception baby steps
millionaire audio book and ebook is
included in the twenty dollars
the legacy journey audio book and ebook
is included in the twenty dollars the
baby steps millionaires live stream
event in january is included in the
twenty dollars a ramsey smart tax tax
filing is included for free in the
twenty dollars and a thirty day free
trial for ramsey plus is included in the
twenty dollars it's over a hundred
almost two hundred dollars worth of
stuff included when you buy a twenty
dollar book now
that's pretty cool so be sure and check
all of that out danielle is with us in
philadelphia hi danielle welcome to the
ramsay show
hi there hi what's up
so a little over a year ago
i married my longtime
boyfriend and
we're not young we're
late 40s early 50s and
we still have two houses now a year
later because
his house is an hour and a half away
from my job
i spend about 240 dollars a month in
gasoline going back and forth i don't do
it every day how far is your house from
his job
um
maybe two hours
so you guys work you guys work two hours
apart
yes
that's wild
his his his job is actually an hour and
a half from his house as well but he's
willing to make that sacrifice i
i'm not i think i think it's cray cray
i think you need to sell both these
houses and buy a house close to your
jobs
well
i agree with that
however i have been in the mindset
lately of well perhaps maybe i could
look for a job closer but my dilemma is
that i have been working in the school
district for 25 years
as a custodial supervisor
and i make about 68 000 a year
my concern is going someplace else and
not making that kind of money i work my
way up to where i am now
there's also another reason i keep my
house because i have extended family
also living in this house right now
why
um
my daughter had two young children and
she got a divorce
and was only making about 13 an hour so
she had a hard time maintaining anything
and um so you're paying a house payment
for her
correct so when's she gonna get on her
feet
well she just got a promotion uh she
started last week
and
it should bump her up to about twenty
dollars
come next month
you need a plan for her to be on her own
and you just sell that house and you
guys ought to sell the house that you
live in
and you ought to move closer to both of
your jobs
this is tough
his job he's making over
a hundred thousand so and he's just a
bus driver in new york city
so um okay so hold on i gotta jump in
i'm going crazy so both of you make good
money and you both are assuming that you
can't do anything else so i want to i
want to frame what you've been doing a
little differently
you're not just a supervisor of
custodians in a education system you are
a leader of people in a specific area
you're a leader oh
it's true oh it's absolutely true well
listen i'm the queen around here i know
you are and here's the deal you got a
lot of experience i just heard some sass
come out we are in the hottest job
market in the history of the united
states and you have something to offer
years and years of experience of leading
people that are in uh you know the
traditional custodial roles and things
of that nature there's a lot of options
for you out there i would also say
we have the greatest need in the history
of the united states in the area of
drivers whether it be
uh your traditional 18 wheelers or other
we have a supply chain problem and i saw
an article just last week there's a need
right now in the united states daniel
for 80 000 truck drivers if he's driving
a bus in manhattan he can drive
something else you guys have got to get
outside of this mindset that we can't
make what we make or more somewhere else
because i don't believe that's true and
you at least owe it to yourselves to do
the research yeah investigate see what
else is out there
i mean you're like there's only one kind
of spaghetti but you've never been to
more than one restaurant that's right i
mean go check out some spaghetti
restaurants keto go look at the jobs
that are on the plate out there and see
what's happening you have a lot of
experience and skill to offer and not to
mention you're the queen that's right
well that comes that the royalty part
should go a long way
i like that yeah
and here's the other thing a house is a
stupid house
yeah i ain't driving an hour and a half
for a stupid house oh that's too short
get you another stupid house
there's stupid houses on every corner
and this idea that you know i'm not well
i've always lived so what
sell it
i am not driving an hour and a half over
a job or a piece of real estate all of
these things can change and we didn't
even discuss the potential financial
gain from those two houses yeah assuming
what their what their position is in
them
absolutely we got to get daughter up and
out
so she can sell that other house but
still oh my gosh y'all there's a lot of
stuff going on here and
you guys are holding on to the past so
tightly you're not going to live well in
the future
yeah the past job history the past i
worked so hard to get here so use that
to go into something else
i've always lived here so use that to
get into something else don't hold on to
the past so tight that you lose your
future all right jeff is with us in
tulsa oklahoma hi jeff how are you
hi dave thanks so much for taking my
call i really appreciate your time we're
honored how can we help
well i'm 56 years old and we're in baby
step seven and i heard you say something
recently that got me to thinking and
that is that social security basically
is a break even if that and i was
wondering what the advantages or
disadvantages
would be like if i were to take out my
social security uh as early as i can
62.65 whatever the age is and invest
that
62 and money
it and don't touch it you'll end up with
more money
yes sir
that's what'll happen that's my question
yeah so the difference in what you get
paid
if you wait to 65
versus 62 would be made up
for in the investment that you create
by investing everything from 62 to 65.
you take all that put into a lump sum
that lump sum will pay more than it
would pay extra if you wait oh and when
you die that money is in your estate
when you die with social security it
disappears
magical government math
just gone poof just like that oh yeah
yeah
yeah the social insecurity system gives
you a negative rate of return
it is an absolute
governmental
disaster
think dmv runs retirement program now
you got it figured out okay this is
what's going on and and so well it was
never designed to be retired programs
designed to be a supplemental yeah it's
designed to be supplemental and a whole
bunch of people are living on it because
we've raised a couple generations now
that think the government is so smart
they're going to take care of you
and if you wait on the government to
take care of you your life is always
going to suck
so he's right just really smart to ask
that question
and say i'm not going to count on social
insecurity when i get to retirement
because i'm going to have actually saved
some of my own money oh and when i do
get the money from the government i'll
never get as much out as i have put in
that means you have a negative rate of
return you don't even get out as much as
you put in
unless you just live to 192
you know and so you're it's a negative
rate of return they are sucking the
blood out of the american public
continually with this disaster of a
program
nobody gonna do anything about it though
but i'll whine a little it's good for me
yeah helps my blood pressure yeah
ken coleman good show this hour and uh
james child's gonna show this hour jenna
on the phones good job
this is the ramsey show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and author of the
brand new book from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love is
my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five kelsey is
with us in connecticut hi kelsey how are
you
hi dave hi ken this is exciting i wasn't
expecting this today well we're honored
to have you how can we help
um i have a career question so my boss
has just asked me if i wanted to take
over her small business it's a gym i'm a
personal trainer but i was actually
planning to join the air force in the
next year and now
i i just feel lost like i don't know
what opportunity to do oh well this is a
fun place to be in uh but i think we've
got to simplify this so your head and
heart were totally focused on going into
the air force for a future there
and when your boss hits you with this it
felt really good didn't it felt nice
that she would trust you enough and it
felt very nice correct
yeah yeah
yeah good but after that wore off
and you begin to really wrestle with
well wait a second i think i was heading
over here what was your heart telling
you right before you made this phone
call which way were you leaning because
i know you were leaning one way
yeah so i've really been leaning towards
the air force i've i've actually been
thinking about that since last um last
march i've just been like
head and heart in there i just couldn't
do it sooner because of medical reasons
good but um so here's the deal i just so
here's the deal are you worried about
letting your boss down or are you
worried maybe what others might say
about turning this on paper
really amazing opportunity to run a
business what's really making you
question what you know
you want to do that's what you have to
answer right now what is what is causing
the doubt about the military decision
um it's a woman's gym and
i'm afraid that if i don't take it over
it's going to close and
i just care about the members a lot got
it okay that's amazing now kelsey you
got to be careful here
to
not misinterpret what is a really
beautiful heart you're a good person and
you have built relationships with those
women you care about them you've
invested in them and if you're not
careful that false guilt
is going to turn into resentment if you
were to do this and take this all for
the right heart reasons
you will be delaying and maybe
completely
moving on from the thing that you know
you're supposed to do and i'm telling
you that will eventually turn into
resentment and you have no reason to
feel guilt
about not taking this business
those women will find other places to
work out you didn't open it you didn't
open it and it's not your responsibility
to take care of their physical life do
you understand what i'm saying
yeah it makes it makes a lot of sense i
think like i talked to my family about
it and of course my family's just gonna
tell me to do
what
you know what i should do but i
i just needed like an honest
not family family-oriented opinion to
kind of steer me in the right direction
let's refocus for just a moment tell me
in 30 seconds or less from your heart
what the future is because you're moving
into the air force what's that look like
and why are you doing it
um
the opportunity to travel
meet a lot of
new people go different places and
um just serve our country which is
something i've been thinking about for a
while that's that's all you need to
focus on there's no guilt here you do
what you believe you're supposed to do
there's no guilt those ladies are gonna
be fine
one of them can take it and run it yeah
you're free kelsey that would do it yeah
thank you
yeah
thanks for the call thank you for being
willing to serve our country you're a
great american absolutely yeah
absolutely incredible
well done all right open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five tyler's in fayetteville arkansas hi
tyler how are you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
so um my main question is so i'm in the
military right now and
what i'm kind of struggling with is
whether or not i should
purchase a home while i'm on active duty
or wait until i transition to the
reserves
right now that looks like a six year
timeline
just to give you some stats i have no
debt i have about three hundred thousand
dollars invested um with a tsp two roth
iras
and a taxable brokerage account good for
you um
yeah oh thank you how much is in the bra
i have about
190 000 in there i believe way to go all
right and how how often will they move
you and during the next six years while
you're still active duty
so i'm in yeah i'm in fort bragg right
now in fayetteville and i will move in
about three years and i eventually uh
after my sixth year want to transition
to the reserves and go to where my
parents yep yeah so you don't need to
buy
and it's not because you don't have the
money you have the money but the problem
is you're going to be moving
and you're in an area that the
uh the properties are largely military
properties
and so you've got a lot of properties
coming on the market because they're
always moving people
and uh it's a little tougher to move a
property in one of these military towns
agreed oh i agree oh i absolutely agree
that's what i was thinking too because
my parents actually just recently moved
to nashville and um knowing how the
housing market is there me and my wife
are trying to decide whether or not to
just
keep investing and piling cash and then
have a ginormous down payment yes and
then buy buy once you've settled into a
place
once you settle into wherever it is
you're settling into
and it's probably after your military
career when you move into the reserves
after your active duty career and thanks
for your service because you're moving
so often that you the house is not going
to go up enough in value
and it's hard to sell them sometimes and
you can get stuck with properties
everywhere you've been stationed
and so when you're moving every two to
three years almost always it's better
off to rent and just pile up some cash
over here for when you settle in now
some branches of the military some jobs
in the military after a while in the
career you will settle in and be in one
location even while active duty for a
long time if you're going to be there a
while like five years plus then yeah you
just start talking about buying
but most of you guys and gals are moved
every two to three years and most of
these markets do not support enough
turnover and do not support a price
increase to justify buying when you're
only holding two to three years you'll
lose money on the transaction if you can
sell it or you'll get stuck with the
thing and end up with rental properties
dotted all over the nation
and you don't want to do that so but
again thank you for your service as well
yeah his theme
is one of my favorite scenes from
braveheart
where the the english are thundering
down the cavalry on wallace and his men
and he says hold
hold
hold
and that's gonna be a great position
when you get out exactly right
exactly right
i love it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org
budget we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
well we're coming into that time of year
when some people get all stressed out
about money it's called christmas
the gifts the travel expenses the extra
food the bills
oh and life still has to go on
but what if money was something that you
never had to fret about stress about
worry about again
what if christmas was actually like
enjoyable and stuff
well you'd need a plan to cause that to
happen and we can show you how to do it
it's called financial peace university
this is the place where we teach you how
to handle money how to get out of debt
how to build wealth how to be
outrageously generous how to live on a
budget how to live on a plan
it's the class you should have been made
to take back when you're in high school
but
back then nobody made you take it
financial peace university and our
premium version of every dollar the
world's best budgeting app goes with
financial peace university when you
become a ramsey plus member it gives you
access to all of this stuff and much
more if you want a free trial of ramsay
plus to try all this out go to
slash ramseysolutions.com plus our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more it's an
incredible american company blinds.com
use ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from daniel in maine i
got a job at a major law firm after my
first year of law school i am now a
third year law student and the firm i
work for wants to hire me after
graduation i would like to own my own
law firm someday and feel like gaining
experience in a smaller firm would be
better to prepare me to achieve that
goal would i be crazy to reject a higher
paying job at a respected law firm to
pursue my dreams you wouldn't be crazy
but i want to challenge this thought
that
you saying
no to this bigger firm
uh and going to work for a smaller firm
is going to somehow prepare you to run
your own firm better because you picture
it being a smaller firm i actually think
that i would consider what you could
learn
from working for a bigger firm and
understanding the complexities of the
business and i think that's just as
relevant as you would scale down
eventually running your own firm so i i
don't know that this is the actual right
narrative that well
if i work for a smaller firm that's
going to better prepare me to run my own
small firm one day i think leadership is
leadership
organization is organization and i think
you'd learn in some ways more from a
larger firm and getting to know their
leaders and those partners and learning
from them taking the higher pay and then
if you feel like that you can get
something unique from a smaller firm
let's move to that eventually so i
wouldn't assume this is the right choice
either way
you've got to learn how to run a
business that's correct
and so the more time you spend being a
lawyer
and the less time you spend on actually
building business acumen regardless of
which location you're in
that's going to take away from your
dream so your dream is you need to
become a great lawyer
but also learn how to run a law firm the
business practices of that so
i think you could get the the business
acumen like ken is saying either place
you've just got to be very intentional
about it you're going to run into
the dichotomy that anyone that has a a
specific discipline or skill runs into
if you paint houses and you do a really
good job and you want to be a painter
and you want to own your own painting
contracting firm
running a painting contracting firm is
different than painting
that's a running of business that's a
different set of skills and so the more
you paint houses
the less you will learn about running a
business and the more
chances of you failing running that
business become so anybody that's a
maker anyone that's a doer like a lawyer
even a doctor yep the more time you
spend actually being a doctor and not
actually running the practice they're
two different things and you can't make
enough to out earn your stupidity so
you've got to learn these business
skills that's correct regardless of
which place you are and the law the
smaller firm could
eat you up as a lawyer and take up all
your time lawyering
as much as the larger firm does so you
just got to be intentional about
wherever you are learning the business
skills yeah and so i think i'm with ken
i think you took the higher paying job i
do too i i just think that's better
because there's some complexities at the
larger firm that you're going to learn
about
amanda's in nashville hi amanda welcome
to the ramsay show
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up in your world um
not a lot i just had a quick question
and i wanted to press this by saying
that i do follow your plan but i've been
trying to diagnose the medical condition
for the past year so as you have a
larger savings than you would approve of
my question is should i refinance my
house to pay off my student loans or
should i sell it pay off the mortgage
should pay off the student loans and
then rent until i can buy again my
husband and i
okay a lot going on here how much is
your student loan debt
uh 137.
what's your degree in
uh my husband is a chiropractor i'm a
medical assistant
okay and what does he make
he makes around 110 i think is it your
student loan or his
it's his
oh
okay
he makes 110.
all right
and um
interesting
and and you make how much
um i make somewhere around 30. but the
household last year i think we brought
home 122 not mistaken
it's going up this year have 130 000 in
student loan debt
yeah 137 137
okay and 63 and savings all together so
you not being able to work is not going
to
because the your income is a the smaller
portion of your household income right
yes and i i'm not you're met you that
have a medical condition or him
it's him oh it's him
oh
so yeah we're both able to work so
you're piling the money up because
waiting on what this diagnosis for him
might be
what has he got
what's going on with him
um i'd rather not say it's just
something that we've had to do a couple
of diagnostics on in the past year
okay well depending on how debilitating
it is and how sure
the diagnosis is correct is
uh the more debilitating and the more
sure you are the more i'm just selling
the house
i'm not refinancing and borrowing your
way out of the debt either way
yeah our thought process there was that
we would be able to lower the interest
rate
it's not an interest rate problem it's a
debt problem
okay
and you have a huge pile of debt so if
you sold your home would it pay off the
student loan and the home
oh yeah everything and you'd be free
okay
so if he's not going to be able to earn
that kind of income to be able to pay
off the student loan
by being a chiropractor that he took out
getting into that he took out to become
a chiropractor because of this medical
diagnosis yeah you need to sell the
house
to reset and to get yourself
positioned to weather this health storm
okay
now the the other question is this um or
the other thing to bring up and because
i
you intentionally are
i've got an incomplete picture because
you're concerned about privacy and i
that's okay all right but let me let me
give you two other pieces of information
that might enter into this
when is are these uh
federal student loans
uh yes they are right now okay well they
need to stay federal student loans
because if he were to pass away they are
forgiven
okay well it's not anything that's
serious it's just more of a yeah
if he were be to be declared permanently
disabled
that's not going to happen either okay
so it's not that extreme okay that's
good yeah that's nothing extreme good
okay so you're gonna pay them so the
only question is how long is he to be
with and you got you just had you guys
have to assess this
the longer he's going to be out of work
or have
hugely diminished income the more i'm
going to lean towards selling the house
but if it's a one-year thing and you
want to hold on that's fine hold on put
the student loans on hardship deferral
come back from the mess and get the
income back up and attack the student
loans and get rid of them i'd be okay
with that yeah i think the other factor
here is how expensive could the
treatment be i felt like there was a
little hint towards that and that's why
i'd still sell the house sets you free
you got plenty of cash plenty of freedom
and income to be able to pay for the
treatment well when you come back and
you're making you're making a hundred
thousand dollars again
after the other side of this and just
buy another house i agree that'd be an
okay thing to do too
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage marcia and cameron are
with us hey guys how are you great how
you doing yeah welcome where do you guys
live uh fort branch indiana just outside
of evansville all right well we got to
get started with i love
the t-shirts
be the third pig
the back is even better what's it say on
the back we're debt free
that's right brick house be the pig in
the brick house the third pig i love it
way to go you guys you're prepared for
the big bad wolf excellent all right how
much debt have you paid off uh we paid
off uh 120 000
very good how long did that take uh
about three years once we really got
working together okay and what was your
range of income during that three years
um 90 up to 1 30. cool what do y'all do
for a living uh i manage a home
improvement center and i'm the founder
and executive director of non-profit
benefiting kids in foster care oh good
very good great good job you guys okay
what kind of debt was the
000
well we were
very normal we had uh
student loans credit cards medical debt
and uh most recently our house wow
yes we did super weirdo i'm looking at
weird people
looking at weird third pigs i like it so
uh what's this house worth uh 225 ish
that's so fun
your house is paid for dude it feels
weird yeah it's just strange i love it
the grass feels better under your feet
yeah ken and i have a good friend down
in atlanta just sent us a video this
morning he paid off his house showed us
hitting the hit and submit on the
computer and then you see their feet out
in the grass like euros youtube picture
just a second ago here yeah the grass
feels different under your feet when you
pay for it way to go guys thank you
thank you so very cool all right there's
a story here how long you been married
13 years okay so three years ago you got
serious yes and you said you you did
qualify you said when we finally got
together and both of us were doing it we
got serious it went zoom zoom tell us
what happened and tell us how you got
plugged into ramsey well
our story goes back probably 10 years
i'm probably the the textbook example of
of how not to do things
i stumbled upon your radio show just
driving one day and
kind of dabbled in it didn't really
you know go full force into the baby
steps or anything but i started
listening to you and and
your principles made a lot of sense so
i started doing some of the the steps
and doing some of the things and
my mistake was i did not bring her in on
it so
although i was making a little bit of
progress
it was really creating a pinch point and
a
stress in our marriage because we
weren't operating off of the same page
and i'm over here trying to do one thing
and she's doing another thing and it
just it wasn't working out so
well and a little bit of backstory to
that is when we we lived in kokomo
indiana it was a 2008 during the
housing crash or flip or whatever it was
and um
we he's going to tell you a little bit
more about that but but i guess what i
was trying to say was uh
dave ramsey was not a good word it was
what would you say a cuss word in our
family yeah um and i was i was the free
spirit that wanted to do whatever i
wanted to do and i was
even though we talked about what you
were the plan i was i was not having it
no not at all so what happened that
caused you to get together and decide to
do it together
um
well going back near to the beginning of
our story uh
near there anyway um we were upside down
on a house
by a lot
and
we got we moved
my job moved us so
we were in a position where we were way
underwater on our house and
fortunately my parents have always
been a big help to us and my dad loaned
me some money about twenty thousand
dollars just to be able to sell our
house and you know write the check to
get out of it
um
and then you know fast forward we were
gonna pay him back it was alone and
uh that very next christmas after
christmas dinner my dad sat us down and
said that his present to us was we
didn't know him that money back anymore
wow so
um
that really did it for me that was kind
of my why because you know it really got
me thinking you know if i
ever want to be in a position to be able
to bless my kids and my family like that
then i really need to do something
different than i've been doing so
i don't know really what was it that
three years ago really put us on it
together so another important fact in
10 years ago we actually owed 216 000
dollars so we came a long way as we as
we marched forward uh to three years ago
um but three years ago he he was just so
excited about your principles and he's
he started he started teaching fbu
classes
and uh and and sitting in that class he
invited me to really be hands-on and
part of it and and i had started
listening to him and your principles and
and i got excited myself and i became
the i don't want to sit at this table
and talk about this i don't like that
name in my house i want to buy whatever
i want to like come on guys you can do
this and um and really the the where we
got gazelle intense was um during the
pandemic uh just a little over i guess
it's been like 15 months now but my dad
was um he was dying
and uh he did not leave a good family
tree as far as finances and and we were
really left with a huge mess
and then i have my own um medical issues
that that i was told that i was a big
high-risk complications from kovid and i
just it just really was an eye-opener
that i have two amazing kids and what if
something happened to one of us in this
time how would i what would that mean
for my family and um
and that was it like i was sold i didn't
care from then on else if we were eating
rice and beans being the rice we were
getting everything paid off and so i
called him at work one day and i said
let's do this we can do this and we're
here we did this and we're grateful and
he's like who are you and what have you
done with my wife
way to go you guys yeah i just want to
know i mean obviously we heard the whole
backstory i want to know you get really
fired up right and so now we've got big
motivators yeah what was the hardest
part once you actually got into it
because there's that initial high this
must be done right conviction and at
what point did you start to struggle or
did you struggle and what'd you do to
get out of that
yeah we did
i think the biggest thing was it was so
different you know we'd never
it was the first time in our marriage
that you know we had really been on the
same page and focusing on the same
common goal and
there's unbelievable power in that you
know we did it for so long
um you know i i we were talking on the
way down here i felt like i was you know
repairing holes in the boat while she's
on the other end drilling bigger ones
and and
you know so just once we really grasped
the concept and started working together
it was so different than anything we'd
ever done that it took us a while to
kind of adjust to that and getting
accustomed to using a budget and
following the every dollar budget but
you know really once
we started on that same page together it
was game on very cool
i used to be the kind of person that i'd
get a couple hundred dollars from a
bonus or something i'd be like oh he
didn't know and i'm shoving that in the
drawer because i'm going to go shopping
and he'd see it when it showed up on
amazon right on my front door or
wherever that was from
and it just became you know what we have
extra money let's do something
intentional with it let's be intense and
it was it was really just getting on the
same page and actually i was sharing
this this story with somebody a couple
weeks ago about being able to be on this
stage and share such a a big win for our
family and changing the family tree and
um and i said you know what i think
another big motivator was knowing this
is not like something that somebody else
can do we can do this every day people
can do it if you if you do it on purpose
and i have to give a plug to my son here
let's get the kids in what are their
names and ages uh jackson and harmony
okay
so jackson twelve and seven twelve and
seven
so jackson is is i think he was born a
nerd like his dad
um and we gave him the give save spend
pigs
many years ago and he was really
diligent about giving and saving giving
and saving
and um he is going to be 13 in february
and by
his 13th birthday he is going to have a
toyota camry paid for with less miles
than my vehicle and
a 3 000 savings account well done
very impressive all right marcia cameron
jackson and harmony harmony from
evansville indiana 120 000 paid off in
three years making 90 to 130 be the
third pig house and everything count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two
one we're dead free
wow what a complete transformation
and the reluctant spouse goes in to help
with financial peace university whoop
whoop there it is
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
he's a number one best-selling author
and his brand new book is out from
paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love patty is with us
in boise idaho hi patty welcome to the
ramsay show hi thank you for taking my
call sure
you had a call a few minutes ago that
piqued my interest and i'm trying to
understand
my husband is losing his job on friday
because he won't take the covet shot and
his company is firing everybody that
will not do it they're not doing
exemptions or anything
he is almost 62 he'll be 62 in just a
couple of months
and we're trying i'm 51 or 51 so i'm a
little bit younger than he is how has he
been with that company
uh seven years wow okay
um and it's been a lot it's been a lot
of going back and forth they kept coming
back and forth and saying you're going
you're not you're going you're not and
finally today they just said no you're
going like everybody
that refuses is just gone
so
what we're trying to figure out is
somebody asked you about early
retirement with social security and one
of the things that he and i wondered is
would it be better for him to take early
retirement because we understand that
investing
that would be better but he's not ready
to quit work and i was under the
impression that if you took
early social security that they ding you
if you are working correct and okay so
you don't get a lump sum that's why no
it's not a lump sum it's monthly income
okay
if you start your social security at 62
you get a smaller monthly income than if
you started at 65.
but then if he continues to work don't
they doing that social security exactly
they will yeah okay so probably
if he's gonna go back to work don't take
social security
okay okay
he would not be happy not not
working he's still got years where he's
going to want to be productive he's not
going to want to just
well i would hope so he's just a spring
chicken
we're the same age so there you go yeah
no and he loves what he does i mean you
know most people go to work and they
come home and leave their work at work
he's he's an inventor and an engineer
and that's what he loves and so he does
it all the time so he's not really ready
to just give that up and so
we weren't sure if taking early
retirement i
from the call it sounded like the guy
was going to take a one lump sum was so
secure
it's not a lump sum they don't offer
lump sum if they did i would have
already taken it okay okay well that
helps thank you early and often as i can
get money from the government that is
mine that i've given them and i'm not
even going to get it all back i would
take all i could get as fast as i could
get it because uh they've been screwing
me for years and so i'd be happy to take
some of it back and that sentence you
just uttered is a total fantasy oh i
know i didn't say it would happen i just
said it'd be nice no i know i'm so
saying we would all be doing that yeah
oh boy
we'll turn into this grumpy old man
molly's in st louis hey molly how are
you
good um thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
we
well i just feel busy
so we have a farm we have a rental
property and my husband has a generator
business
and our money
i feel like our money's in a good place
um
but
the farm operation
is a little tricky to wrap our brains
around like
how
to get it to where it's debt-free but
also like the motivation behind it
because
like if you
if you so we use an operating loan
while the crops are being put out and
all that
um
so it gets paid
back
uh gets paid down to zero but
um if we
so if we buy if we save to buy land you
can't
deduct that
purchase
so you have to pay tax on anything
what's your question
if
how do we get rid of our
operate i'm not really sure honestly how
do we get rid of our operating loan
uh like what's the motive behind that
when
we would have to pay so much in tax to
build up enough money to
to have the cash to do that
okay
um
you understand a tax deduction
is not a tax credit
so the operating loan does not benefit
you
for taxes
except for 25 percent of the interest
that you pay
there's almost zero tax benefit for an
operating loan
did you know that
um
i thought our i thought what we paid on
that was part of our farm expense
no not for not not the principal only
the interest
okay only the interest okay and so let's
let's put how big is the operating loan
typically
um
our limit is 225 the max was ever done
is like 160. okay so
let's just use some crazy numbers okay
let's say you did 160 000
and it cost you
uh
eight percent of that and so it cost you
or ten percent of that it wouldn't be
that much what's your interest rate
four percent okay four percent all right
and so it costs you what sixteen
thousand it
costs you about four thousand dollars in
interest
yeah no it cost you about
six thousand seven thousand dollars in
interest okay well seven thousand
dollars in interest is all that's
deductible nothing else is deductible
correct okay now the seven thousand
dollar tax deduction
if you're in a thirty percent tax
bracket
saves you two thousand one hundred
dollars in taxes
okay so you're screwing around with 160
thousand 000
for a 2 000 benefit and calling that
sophisticated that's not sophisticated
no i think the issue is more
we're not it's not really that to get
the deduction it's
it's like
okay so
then i misspoke okay um
so if i
in order for us to build up like
you have to pay taxes on 160 000 worth
of income to have 160 000
yes that's how life works yeah
yeah
yeah but that's what you need to do
to get out of the operating loan
business because all you got to have is
one bad crop in your bankruptcy
do you make in a year on the farm do you
think
um this last year
after we did everything we'll have like
a hundred thousand okay income and so so
let's pretend and let's say okay you
need hundred and sixty so let's say over
four years we're going to take 40 000 a
year and we're going to borrow 40 000
less each year
because the 100 000 in profit you pay
taxes on you don't have a choice
okay so after you pay taxes on your
hundred thousand dollars i want you to
put forty thousand dollars aside each
year for four years that will equal 160
000
now you are your own line of credit
because you actually have some freaking
money
and i'm curious really quick molly i'd
love dave to hear this i want to hear
this how much is the rental property
worth what do you owe on it
uh we don't know anything on the rental
property what's it worth probably worth
450. what kind of profit does the
generator business make
so
real quick generally we take home five
thousand a month okay okay so
60 000 on that so you're making 160 000
a year you've got a 450 000
rental property if i were in your shoes
i'd sell the rental property and fund my
operating line that's what i'm thinking
you're 100 debt free you're operating
the business debt free you're going to
increase your you're going to decrease
your hassle
because you're dealing with a renter a
generator business and a farm
okay so you're going to decrease the
craziness where you're chasing your tail
when you started the call you talked
about how confused you were
and um and you're getting rid of the
debt which lowers the stress of the
situation and you're paying cash for
everything on the farm from this day
forward and you're paying cash for
everything in the generator business
from this day forward and you never fall
for the tax deduction myth again because
when you fall for the tax deduction myth
and you call that smart really what
you're saying out loud is i love trading
dollars for quarters
because that's what a tax deduction does
it trades a dollar for a quarter
and you don't want trade dollars for
quarters
so don't stay in debt for the tax
deduction and don't stay in debt because
you think you have to you don't have to
effectively you are borrowing against
your rental property once a year for an
operating loan
that's what the balance sheet says
it's technically not a loan on the
rental property i got that but
effectively that's what you're doing
yeah so you can clean up your whole life
pretty quickly if i were in your shoes
and i wanted to be a farmer i'd sell the
rental property
if i didn't want if i want to be a
rental landlord and not be a farmer i'd
sell the farm
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
his new book is out and on the
bookshelves and at
ramseysolutions.com flying out the door
it's called from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love so
if you want to talk about career and
jobs this hour well mr ken coleman is
here to help
and of course i'm here to help you with
your life and your money we started
pre-sale on my first book in eight years
wow yesterday i didn't how's that feel
it's been a long time since you put a
book out it feels old
but um
yeah i mean basically i've been putting
your all's books out first i know so now
now you're on the cover now i have 10
ramsey personalities and putting putting
out books on tim ramsey personalities
and supporting and pushing out those
brands and helping those has been my job
for
eight or ten years and so the last book
i did was actually with rachel so she
and i did number one bestseller called
smart money smart kids um and she was of
my daughter rachel cruz is one of the
ramsey personalities and so um this
one's uh not got anybody's name on it
but mine and it's all about the people
that have followed the baby steps and
have become millionaires and it's the
proof text to prove to you
that you can too
not billionaires
millionaires
have a one million dollar net worth or
greater
and there's
that that's you you would want more than
that probably that's not enough maybe i
don't know but it's a million and it's
million more than most people got it
yeah so if you want to be a baby steps
millionaire we can show you how and
following the baby steps gets you there
and this is a
you know truly
motivational book to show you exactly
with the math exactly with statistics
exactly what will happen with the
arithmetic if you follow this process
you will get there and it also pretty
much tears up anybody's who tears
anybody's butt up who says you can't do
it and so i spent a few chapters tearing
up those butts little whack-a-mole in
there a little whack-a-mo a little
chapter little uh solve the objection to
make the sale thing so uh people that
tell you you can't win i don't like
those kind of people so it's my job to
tear their butt up that's the thing so
um it's what we do so baby steps
millionaires on sale now it actually
comes out january the 11th if you
pre-order it you get all kinds of
goodies including e-books and books and
100 worth of stuff so check it all out
at ramseysolutions.com chad is in
minneapolis hey chad how are you
better than i deserve how are you
just the same sir what's up
so i've got a question um
my fiance and i have very different
views on money we're going to get
married next next summer
congratulations
yeah thank you uh
grew up on a farm working saving you
know striving for a better life it
wasn't that i was destitute when i was
growing up but you know it was it was
not always the easiest thing
her mom had her
my my fiance's
grandfather passed away and her mom had
inherited millions of dollars
never had to work and ended up raising
nine kids on her own after her dad left
um and sort of abandoned the family
and then ended up using the money that
she had inherited to
manipulate the kids into doing things
into
thinking the way that she did doing
things for her
but ultimately has left sort of a bad
taste in her mouth with money
how do i work with her to show her that
money isn't
intrinsically evil um i am i'm the
breadwinner i i have a very good career
um you know i make about 120 she makes
38.
how how do i work with her to show her
that money's not bad
how old are you guys
uh
36 and 38. okay
okay
um either one of you been married before
both of us have actually so we're we're
combining
i've got four boys she has two girls
okay
well let me tell you some statistical
things to think about and these are
things you can go over with her
okay
um one of the things you want to do
anytime you want to enter into anything
in business we would study
if you want to enter into marketing we
would study marketing and emulate best
practices find best practices and find
where the landmines are we want to avoid
the mind landmines keep from getting
your leg blown off right and we want to
emulate people who are winning we want
to copy the things that the people that
are winning are doing agreed
okay so here's what you guys are facing
it's not insurmountable by the way
but it is an uphill climb
you have three major strikes against
your marriage before it even starts
you don't address these
i'll give you a high probability of
failure
okay
number one
her
family upbringing was toxic
she comes from a highly dysfunctional
family
number one
hard to have relationships when you have
come from a highly dysfunctional family
unless you've dealt with it
did i did i misstate that
no okay number two
you both have failed at marriage before
and if you have not healed through those
failures and learned from those failures
um you will replicate the exact same
stupid crap again
high probability of failure if you do
not deal with that that's right number
three
the number one cause of divorce in north
america today
money disagreements money fights and
money problems and you're already having
those
you have to solve all three of those
before the summer
and and to be honest with you so in in
both both of our um both of both of us
chose to leave our marriages
due to
a lot of issues unfortunately i we we
knew each other's
exes so we we saw it there was a lot of
people that saw it um yeah wonderful you
still both failed at marriage listen
dude you got what i'm trying to tell you
is you guys need a lot of one-on-one
counseling pre-marriage counseling to
deal with these three issues before you
walk down the aisle otherwise
statistically you have a very high
probability of hitting the wall yeah
don't miss this i'm not trying to say
you can't make it i'm just saying dude
there's land mines everywhere and i'm
trying to guide you through them and you
need a coach a counselor that they can
talk to the two of you that is excellent
that is world class this is not two
little puppies getting married and they
need some little pat on the hand
pre-marriage counseling you need to deal
with divorce healing you need to deal
with her toxic upbringing because her
mother's crazier than a freaking bean
man what you described to me is
dangerous stuff
and then on top of that you're in total
disagreement have different value
systems about money and you boiled it
down to she thinks money's evil that's
not the problem here that'll be one of
14 things that come up while y'all
unpack this yeah chad i hope you're
hearing this you need to pause this
wedding date until this stuff gets fixed
we didn't say not marry her we said
pause well i don't even need to pause it
you just gotta do the work between now
and summer well i i appreciate that dave
it's very optimistic i i think it's
pause until we get healthy and on the
same page of this and i'd say this she's
gonna have to see a desired future that
you both agree on that money helps us
get there that's eventually where you're
gonna have to get her if you can't agree
about money you're not gonna agree about
life
and you guys really do have some work to
do to get ready for this marriage i
think you can do it but you're not gonna
do it if you'd ignore it
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
have you guys heard that the real estate
market is crazy what what are you
talking about nuts
buyers out there i think they got a buy
there's a line around the block multiple
bids every stinking house listing is an
auction
i mean out of freaking control and
mortgage interest rates are
lower i don't know how they can get any
lower they're going to pay you to take a
mortgage soon i think hey don't get me
wrong a low rate's a good idea it's not
a green light to do stupid stupid as in
buying before you're debt free or with a
zero down payment or just lining up and
paying like way too much for something
because you're out of control hey get
your head out of the craziness for a
second look at you
and your situation
are you debt-free
you have a good strong down payment
saved preferably 20 that'll avoid pmi
right can you really afford home
ownership do you really want the
responsibility you know somebody's got
to cut the grass hello
if and only if your answer is a big fat
yes to all those questions then buying a
home is a really smart move for you
and it's easy to get caught up in all
the crazinesses out there which is why
you need the facts go use our free
mortgage calculator to figure out what
you can actually afford with the
mortgage options that are out there
go to ramseysolutions.com
click free tools
to check it out
free tools to check it out
josh is with us in greenville south
carolina hey josh what's up
hello sir gentlemen thank you for your
time in advance uh my question is i
am selling my home back up in indiana
it's
set to close on the 30th and
i have not heard this question yet uh
how do i keep myself from feeling like
i've hit a jackpot and
keep myself
more along the lines of adulting i am
going to admit that i've been like
ramsay-ish along the way but i do have
plans to get my uh debt paid off
and say that's such a good question yeah
that is very good
how much is the house selling for dude
uh i i asked for 135 and i originally
bought the home nine years ago about 86
so i'm looking at roughly 50 something
thousand dollars in your pocket and
you've never seen fifty thousand dollars
in your pocket
not in one lumps and no sir how old are
you
i am 32. okay good for you man
congratulations
and that is a very mature good solid
question to answer how do i how do i be
smart wise adult with fifty thousand
dollars instead of a child that says who
i hit the lottery well so i got a
question i'm going to add my question on
to his question
there's got to be a psychology and
you've experienced it where there is a
rapid change in in money just period
what does it do to your head and heart
you know the only way i've been able to
work through it and i have to work
through it regularly because
uh sometimes my emotions still operate
um
you know making
one jillionth of what i make now
uh and so i mean we spend more on copier
paper in ramsey than i used to make in a
year you know so
uh it's weird it's an emotional sure
it's an emotional swing
so the way i do that is just you know
john dr john delaney says facts are our
friends yeah
and so uh what i would tell you to do
josh is just write down a lot of facts
facts are
that emotionally 50 000 feels like a lot
of money but actually the arithmetic on
it is it's not much
right
you know and so like facts are i can buy
this or this or this but then i'd have
nothing facts are
i i want to do this with it so that i
can turn 50 000 into 500 000 over the
next 10 years with the house by or
whatever it is what are my facts
not my feelings
feelings will lie to your butt
yes sir and so that that's what you're
fighting against and that just means
you're just like a a real person because
we all fight against that but the
feeling is like oh man like woohoo i've
hit the lottery but then the facts are
i could fritter this away real quickly
and i really would end up with two ugly
cars and that's it you know or something
you know it would just be bad and then
you'd be mad at yourself for like a
decade for the having screwed this up
and that's a fact those are facts and
you know it won't hurt to sit down at
the computer and just write some of
those things down like write yourself a
note that says you know hey let's be a
grown up here you know i i have
attendance i could be a lottery winner
and act like i'm in high school and but
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good that's what
i want to add josh while you're writing
down what dave asked you to write down i
want you to write down what your future
looks like what are you dreaming about
because dave here's what's going on
you're absolutely right
uh feelings
are always present focused
exactly
exactly
plans
was future focus wisdom is an act of the
will yeah i want to think about distance
vision is an act of the will that's it
and i think the desired future if you
plan it out and then you say where does
this new found money this 50 000. how
does it plug into that and what that
does is that unplugs it from friday
night 100 now we got discipline it
unplugs it from a visit to target
that's right or hey none of those things
are none of these things are wise right
because he could be tempted to buy a new
car he's got the cash but wait a second
where are you
or you allocate 2 000 of it to blow
to get it out of your system then it'll
go i'm going i'm going to be wise with
the other 48. i actually like that plan
because it gets the celebration factor
let's celebrate this is a nice blessing
yeah but then let's be big boys and big
girls it doesn't hurt to allocate some
of it to generosity as well yeah but
that also helps but the the
the big thing is is to actually do what
you're doing with this phone call which
is be intentional and be careful and be
thoughtful because where there is no
vision the people perish dalton is with
us in carbondale illinois hey dalton
what's up
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve man what's up in your life
uh i just turned 20 and um
i'm gonna be honest all throughout high
school i kind of
was a knucklehead i mean i didn't say no
i didn't
by the way that comes with the deal
daughter
ken was a knucklehead all the way
through high school man
you know man i wasn't even a knucklehead
i was just an idiot
yeah welcome to the humanities
yeah i um got really bad grades and all
that and
uh now i'm kind of looking more towards
the future now that life has kind of hit
me yeah i'm still left at home i've got
a paper route i make about 20 000 a year
um and i'm thinking about going into the
military
so they'll pay me to go to school as
well as um
i would like to serve my country it'd be
an amazing thing and i'm thinking about
going into the police force
and it's pretty seamless to go from that
um into a city police uh where i'm at
um i don't actually need a college
education for it but um
if it's paid for you know i thought that
i might as well take it um but my main
thing is my family isn't quite on board
with me going into the army why just
because they're
they're very very scared
um
mainly because
i'm not sure if i want to go active duty
yet or not oh they're just worried about
your safety
100 oh yeah that as well as um
i didn't tell you i am uh 17 000 in debt
i found you just a little too late
um i got into
a 400 car payment so dalton before i run
out of time what's your question honey
um i was just wondering uh
what i should do as far as the military
as well as um working my way out of debt
in the meantime got it ken well i i got
to tell you i think i heard your heart
here and i think if you want to serve
our country i would not chase the
military option just as an education
fund it's not a bad move it's nothing
moral about it but i want you to decide
why do you really want to serve our
country uh and i think it's in that
answer of being a police officer you
want to protect and serve and so i say
go
be sensitive to your parents they're
concerned about your safety but i think
you've got to do what your heart's
telling you to do and the good news is
you can pay off that car loan uh you're
20 you didn't find dave and ramsey
solutions too late you can pay that off
in no time i mean you're making 20 from
a paper route what if you went right now
in this market where people are looking
for anybody with a pulse and they'll pay
them 15 an hour minimum wage how can you
go get another job pay that 17 000 off
really quickly and then step into the
military serve your country and then
find a way to step into a police force
and protect and serve your community i
think you got to do what you want to do
you're heading in the right way young
man
um
just move slowly and make sure you spend
a lot of time uh
beating up the recruiter for the best
possible deal yeah on what it is you're
signing up for and that you get into an
area of the military that's going to
serve your long-term dreams and serve
your educational dreams make sure you
get all of that in the package
you might even have your dad or mom
involved with you in negotiating with
the recruiter
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
oh now this is fun
this is fun right here in the lobby of
ramsay solutions on the debt free stage
our good friends
dr andrea and jim are with us all the
way from bowling green ohio i got that
right that's correct good friends of
ramsey been friends a long time and
you're here to do a debt-free scream we
are yeah i love it
you know here's a weird fact for you
this is the second bowling green ohio
debt-free scream in a week really what
are the chances of that stinky little
town it's wonderful the lady was a big
uh the kids were at the university they
were falcons right yes yeah yeah cool
all right andrea how much debt have
y'all paid off we have paid off 158 000.
how long did this take 24 months you
rock wow and your range of income during
that time it was we started off at 130
and then we ended at 190. okay i know
the answer but the listeners don't what
do you guys do for a living i am a
clinical child psychologist and i'm a
capital project manager awesome very
cool and what kind of debt was your 158
000
well 46 000 was my student loan debt for
being going earning a phd over 10 years
of higher ed um he didn't come into the
relationship with any debt and then the
other 112 was our house
we are looking at weird people
i love it way to go you guys what's the
house worth uh 300 000 we checked zillow
just before we came up here
i like that he was ready i had it
appraised 10 minutes ago yeah
i was a project manager well done you
guys well done so a phd and a project
manager and a house worth 300 grand and
you guys are how old 38 wow
36. on your way to being baby steps
millionaires if you're not already well
done you guys i'm so proud of you thank
you it's neat and i'm proud of you as
your friend too so very very well done
good stuff
all right so what inspired you 24 months
ago to get on this horse and make sure
it's done well it's a little bit broken
up so we did it in two phases so back in
december of 2013 when i earned my phd
and we had that 46 000 we decided hey
we're just gonna we're not gonna pay a
penny to sally may we're just gonna get
rid of it in that six-month grace period
and so we just lived off of one salary
and we paid off the 46 000 in that sixth
month grace period before we had any
interest so we got rid of that and then
we took a little bit of a break we
bought some stuff we bought some stuff
with cash with cash but you were on baby
steps four through six at that point
because you're working on your house
absolutely
no other debt left but the house at that
point correct right and we had some
twins via ivf which is a pretty penny if
anyone's done ivf um it costs quite a
bit of money so we had that and we also
bought three cars in that amount of time
with cash and not new um and then
probably in december of 2019
that's kind of when we got intense about
it with paying off the house over the
course of the years we had led financial
peace university and we had walked
alongside people and one of us would say
like hey we're teaching financial peace
university we're really supposed to be
paying off the house early
and then the other one would run the
numbers and that person would be like
it's not worth it i'd be the one running
the numbers saying it's not worth it
and i would be like well maybe we should
try and he'd be like uh
no i wanna i wanna live a little bit and
i was like okay
and then we'd run some more people
through financial peace and i'd be like
we really should pay off the house
and then in december 2019 he looked at
me and he was like he ran the numbers
again and oh we should pay off the house
oh no there it is jim what changed uh
well when i was doing it early you know
you just buy a house you get a 15-year
mortgage how much sacrifice am i gonna
have to make to pay it off you know two
years early you know it's a ton of
sacrifice there when you're really early
to uh to pay it off that much early and
then we just after seven years or six
seven years it's like oh okay the number
i can hit is much smaller now and i
actually felt attainable i felt
attainable yeah i could do oh in 18
months in in 12 months if we really
buckle down we can actually do this and
really having that ability to do it was
like all right let's let's get after it
and we paid it off so cool and then it
was funny because then in december of
2020 when we sat down to set up our each
of our individual goals i was like hey
for a financial goal let's pay off our
house by may
and he ran the numbers again and he's
like there's no way we can do that and i
was like but let's set it as a goal and
he's like there's no way and then
he's going to love this background we
paid in may 21st of 2021
wow wow way to go you guys how's it feel
to not have a payment in the world
absolutely wonderful yeah it's great
it's if you run the numbers on that
oh yeah give him a minute dave i i've
done the numbers of you know also hit
zillow right before you came up with
you know how much per year all that what
are we going to have in 20 years all
that's done but uh it's just the the
ability to know that you know whatever
i'm whatever i have is we own everything
that we have and that any dollar that's
coming in if i'm spending a dollar like
i don't have to worry about that right
it provides us freedoms like oh i can
help someone out you know i you know we
can make independent decisions of like
oh we don't you know our ability to make
financial decisions of just on the spot
is so much higher and being able to
feel that when someone's needs something
or we want to do something it's just
it's done there's no worry about it
because we know we have the money and i
think the other thing with that is that
not only financial decisions but we can
also make career changes so after we
paid off the house in may we actually
both changed careers
in june of this year and so we both
started new jobs because we had the
financial security of we didn't have any
more debt wow good for you that's very
cool yeah because you know it's um i can
work where i want now
it changes everything you know i don't
have anybody breathe i don't have
anything breathing down my neck that
says i have to stay in this environment
i can do it it's really interesting the
psychology there because it gives you
guys a little bit more confidence to
make the move because it's a big deal to
switch yeah to pivot there's a whole lot
of unknowns there absolutely give you
that extra confidence it's really
interesting i gotta know all right so
you're going maybe may he's like i don't
think so maybe you just wore him down
what was the intensity i'm just curious
what was the most intense thing you guys
did to meet that stretch goal because it
feels like it was a stretch it wasn't
even really a stretch because what we
did was i had opened a private practice
in 2020 2020 and we just didn't touch
that money we just kind of set it aside
so then at the end of 2020 we just took
all the money out of the private
practice and just threw it at the debt
and then oh i see so jim was spending
that money and that's why i didn't think
it was possible yeah it was in his
spreadsheet
it was in the spreadsheet yeah and it's
really you know when you get that really
you took a second job really of his
second career you just put that all
towards it although it didn't feel like
that because it was where we wanted to
go career-wise anyway and just kept you
know two jobs at the the same time and
then made the transition fully for her
to private practice after we paid it off
i love it i'm so proud of you guys thank
you well done well done all right when
you're teaching financial peace
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is the key is budget
i cannot tell you the number of times
just sit down and have a budget meeting
with your spouse and sit down and run
the numbers and give every single dollar
a name
and just the
just the amount of people realizing when
they actually sit down and do a budget
and be like i should have a thousand
dollars more this month where is it
going and i'm like i don't know you tell
me you're the one spending it and then
it's just life-changing and marriage
changing it changes your marriage when
you no longer have to fight about money
yeah
very cool all right jim have you run the
numbers when you're going to be a
millionaire
uh yes it's
soon if not happened so
he's
he's already there he's already there
way to go baby steps millionaires i love
it
this is why i come down here and work
still just for this there it is there it
is i'm so proud of you guys well well
done very well done
excellent excellent stuff all right who
are your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you um
probably your parents yeah probably my
parents and you know my family's been
you know my mom got me the uh totally
money makeover when i was in college
my dad would watch you i believe fox
business on like saturday morning
financial peace baby yeah yeah i mean
yeah so they just gave me that
my grandparents you know it was always
you know not having debt and just you
know being able to pay for things and
blessed me with not having any you know
debt going coming out of college
um and so that's just kind of my
family's just you know grown up in that
and
and so they were really just just living
living how we live you know dr andrea
and jim
158 000 paid off 24 months house and
everything not even 40 years old
we suspect they're baby
i love it
making 130-190 a year count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Music]
this is how it's done boys and girls
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalms 86 11 teach
me your way lord that i may rely on your
faithfulness
give me an undivided heart that i may
fear your name
dr martin luther king said you don't
have to see the whole staircase just
take the first step
boy there's so much in that
so much in that just take the first step
bj's with us in baltimore hi bj welcome
to the ramsay show hi
thanks for taking my call we just love
you guys um we were doing the dave
ramsey
and we paid off all of our debt except
for our house way to go
um when we had a second mortgage so we
just have the regular mortgage now
so um the question is i have a lot of
health issues and as
i've um
i've had to go to a natural doctor
because the regular doctors weren't
working
and my husband has a year and a half
before he retires
and my aunt has offered to sell us her
trailer but we would have to relocate
and the question is
should we take early retirement
and then take the the difference
because she's practically giving it to
us
um
should we should he take early
retirement and then pick up another job
because he would need something to do
because we could actually live on his
early retirement or should he continue
working where he's at and then possibly
just rent a place and but all the
rentals are more than what are what we
would pay what do you owe on your home
we owe a
125. and what does he make
he makes uh 80.
do you not like your home
i have health issues i can't go up and
down steps
the bathroom is up on the second floor
and in the basement
so you need to sell the house for your
health reasons
yes to get you into a one-level property
we could live in the basement which has
a bathroom but it's
who really wants to live in a basement
yeah amen okay
and so your houses would sell for how
much
it would sell for uh 200 to
uh
either 180 to 200 000.
and you owe 125.
yes
okay
why don't you sell it and buy a one
bedroom
or i'm sorry a one level house
around a 150.
well in this area
if you can sell yours for 200 you can
buy something for 150 that's not that
dissimilar to what you're living in
if yours sells for 200 150 175 will buy
a very nice one level on your freaking
street
okay you know this is a large house
that's got an apartment in the basement
it's all been redone okay
so sell it for 200
and buy yourself a nice
one level house for 150 to 175.
okay
so it wouldn't be a problem to have
another mortgage
because he retires in a year and a half
nope because he's going to keep working
after he retires and he makes enough to
live on when he retires i'm not moving
you into a trailer
that's going down in value
there's not a good enough deal in the
world to move into a trailer
there's not a good enough deal in the
world to live into a trailer that's
going down in value and this be your
signature golden years no thank you
all right so i think i think you're sick
of these stairs and you know you're just
grasping at straws trying to get out of
there but here's the principle bj that
you need to hear
okay okay if you're gonna sell a house
in a market and buy a house in the same
market
you're going to sell in the like things
are crazy over there right
yeah so you're going to sell in crazy
and you're going to buy in crazy so this
is a net net it's not a net loss it's
not i i sold low and bought high i sold
high and bought high
it's a net net so it doesn't prohibit
you from making the move and you you
know now if you move from a
crazy low market to a crazy high market
you know you might have an argument then
but if you moved on your same street
you you can move down in house down in
price and get into one level three
bedroom house
and that's smaller than the one you're
living in and do it in the 150 to 175
range uh if your current home really is
worth 200. now dave you were so certain
about the trailer what if it has a
redwood deck does it change your opinion
what if it has an outdoor above ground
pool you were still
you were so certain dave
i was like wait a second
i feel like you oversimplified that
oh i'm just talking about things i'm
talking about things that go down in
value that's absolutely right i couldn't
resist i'm not above any of that in
terms of being a snob that's not the
point the point is the stinking things
go down in value yeah and they're
basically a car you sleep in
alex is with us in new york city alex
how are you redwood you didn't see that
one coming i didn't see that okay what's
up alex
hey dudes ken how are you we're doing
great man what's up
so
i kind of have like a part i guess
student loan and retirement questions so
i was
as they say i was dumb and i went to out
of state school and um i let my folks
handle a lot of the
student loan stuff and borrowed
more than i needed so
um
so yeah long story short i paid off the
loans in my name to the point where my
employer will pick up
um the payments the minimum payments and
then the big one is the pan plus loans
that i'm also paying on um
uh that right now i got it down to 150
150 000. wow um
so your parents took out parent plus
loans but you've agreed morally to pay
them
yes you're not legally obligated but you
you that's the deal between you and your
mom and dad
yes okay and your student loans are all
gone
uh all except for eight thousand but my
employer they're paying um a certain
amount per month on it what's your
degree in
accounting what do you make
uh right now make 80. how old are you
24. master's degree in accounting
no uh i decided to go to community
college for the 1503 so i was smart with
that i decided not to uh build a
master's degree
you went to a community college for 150
000 in student loans debt on a parent
plus loan no
no no no no so i went to uh uh an out of
state college four year um
so most of
what is it 180 ended up being for the my
four years and then
i just cash flowed 2000 for community
college
because for accounting you need 30 extra
credits so i just did a community
college instead of masters
oh i see what you're doing okay yeah
you're talking about credit you're
talking about getting your cpa okay
all right okay okay okay okay so you're
24 and you're making 80 grand
all right yeah well you got 150 to go
my question was like i wasn't sure like
if since it's not in my name oh yeah
it's in your name you shook your daddy's
hand
all right
yeah yeah this is your you took on this
debt your you claimed this debt i heard
you a minute ago
yeah i don't care if the law doesn't say
you owe it but the law of the of your
household says you owed it because
you're a man and you gave your word
yes that's yeah so you're gonna pay it
yeah going to treat it like your debt
because it is your debt
the technicality of the legal
technicality don't get you out of it
you're going to pay it anyway so you're
going to pay it like it's your debt
because it is your debt now you took it
on so yeah 50 000 bucks a year for three
years you're done and that means you're
on beans and rice rice and beans or
forty thousand dollars a year for four
years and you're done
by the way your income is going to
increase dramatically from 80 as you
move on from 24 years old up to an
accounting degree and so all of those
increases do not go to partying or
having fun in new york they go to paying
off daddy's loan that you promised him
you would pay
yeah did i read your mail all right
he was just running his weekend schedule
through his head right there
just cancelled that vacation that
all-inclusive in jamaica that's what
just happened yellow yeah you got to
clean this mess up dude
[Laughter]
and the fast deeper you sacrifice the
faster you'll get out that's the formula
and the faster you get out the better
life you're going to have live like no
one else so later you can live and give
like no one else great job ken coleman
thanks for having me great job
james jim jim
jimmy's in there we'll be back before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com